i was rooting for the bills i didn't
know who i was actually gonna be rooting
for when the game started as it started
though i was going yeah i want the bills
to win but i'd pick the ravens cause my
brains thought the ravens would win a
tight close football game and obviously
that didn't happen but man all four
games we had this weekend were fun to
watch that included you know and uh
weather elements everything kind of
played an issue in that football game
altogether
yeah well the wind affected justin
tucker on saturday night and 17-3 i mean
look it really was an exciting game
until the moment of the tehran johnson
pick six that's when it all changed and
then lamar jackson exits with a
concussion and it was just yeah kind of
this weird vague sense that maybe maybe
no there was no maybe after that the
ravens were done the bills advance all
right it's superlatives time chris
divisional round edition i'll let you go
first maybe we'll have a new song for us
coming out of one of these four games no
i don't think we will but i was gonna
start there with don't forget about us
and the bill's defense i mean that they
deserve a little love we've talked about
the bill's offense josh allen all year
long the bill's defense kind of got
steamrolled against the colts last week
you know you and i we picked the ravens
to win the game because we thought man
they'll steamroll the bill's defense the
ravens offense and lamar will make a few
throws to win the game i think that's
what we both thought but just like can't
give enough credit to leslie frazier
sean mcdermott the defensive game plan
you could see really pretty early on
that baltimore other than that first few
runs of the game you went
oh this is good there's a lot of people
in line of scrimmage and the bills have
you know a well thought out attack you
could see there was people always there
to make the tackle no matter what kind
of run game design it was and there we
are 10-3
bills make that great drive to start the
second half
baltimore's answering and you're going
wow man we're going to have a 10-10
football game here maybe 10-6 something
like that and that interception to ron
johnson not only awesome by him but as
like chris collins were said on the
telecast too
davious white getting on his horse and
giddy up giddy up trey davis white
making that block that was big time too
and uh bill's defense a lot of credit to
them we doubted them i doubted them they
came through big time
yeah and what did you name that
superlative what did you have a name for
uh don't forget about us don't forget
about us i said all right
i'll i'll do this similar uh the similar
vein for mine and uh
wait where's trade here davies with the
right there screening off uh lamar
jackson and tyron johnson the rest of
the way josh allen said after the game
that's a play they'll be talking about
for years in buffalo and well that was
the moment where they knew they were
getting back to the afc championship for
the first time since 1993. now the
question is can they finish the job
against the chiefs and get all the way
to the super bowl can you imagine what
the scene will be at the buffalo airport
if they beat kansas city in kansas city
on sunday mike i mean we saw what it was
after they they clinched the division
title for the first time since 95.
it will go crazy it'll be amazing to see
it won't be good for the pandemics
purposes but it'll be amazing to see
well tuscaloosa last monday night wasn't
good for the pandemic purposes either
and it looked it looked and it's like
act like you've been there before you've
won 14 national championships it's not
like it's not like it's the first time
ever it was that many people out we
didn't talk about that last week but
good god so yeah folks there's still a
pandemic going on make your make your
decisions accordingly uh
defense wins championships we talked
about it last hour devon white and what
the tampa bay buccaneers did stiffening
to slow down the saints until the
buccaneers offense could wake up in the
second half and also serving up a short
field with uh yeah the the interception
return the fumble return that devin
white was there you know how we see so
many times where there's a ball on the
ground and defensive players freak out
and
and they you know they misplay it they
try to pick it up and run with it and it
keeps popping around and the offense
eventually recovers it
i
we can't take for granted the skill
level that is required and the presence
of mind that we saw from devon white the
guy's the complete package the ball's
there it pops a couple times he just
scoops it up and goes there's no doubt
ball mine gone and uh set up the
touchdown that made it 20 to 20 and that
that was the moment between antoine
winfield ripping it out and devin white
scooping it up and turning it into very
favorable field position defense still
wins championships and that's going to
be key this weekend against the green
bay packers they need that defense to
step up and play and you got plenty of
young guys that haven't played in the
snow and in the cold and it's that again
it's the tom brady influence that is
going to get them ready he'll he'll be
telling them all week about what it's
going to take i'm surprised he hasn't
lobbied that they they go up and spend
the week in green bay and practice
outdoors to get ready for it who knows
maybe they'll have something like that
up their sleeve maybe they'll have a
giant meat locker all out of the
original rocket try they'll practice in
this week yeah no you know there's
nothing they're going to be able to do
to get ready for the cold
and that's going to be something to
watch for
i played in tampa i can seriously say
when we would go north and play in the
cold weather it was a thing it was a
thing with our football team there's no
doubt we'd walk into new england early
in december and you'd walk in and you'd
go man
we haven't even got outside yet and
there's guys with winter hats and
jackets on we haven't even we're inside
it's it's 71 degrees in the locker room
and we're already bundled up and cold
you knew we had a you know so that is
going to be something to watch for and
if it's 22 degrees out hey i i know just
like a team from the cold weather when
you got to go play a a team like tampa
in september and it's 95 degrees out and
you melt in the heat well sometimes the
hot weather teams you know they freeze
in the cold this time of the year that
will be like a true factor of the
football game and of course green bay
relishes it and that's where i'll go
lombardi will be proud as my superlative
you know the frozen tundra of the green
bay packers but the way green bay played
in that football game the other day the
other day toughness running the football
defense that's where they're different
from last year this is not the same
packers football team that we saw last
year
they kind of have shown us this all
through december you know to where you
and i know i think we were both around
thanksgiving going
green bay's good but are they great i
don't know how good they really are
and here over the last month
i mean i don't know right now i might be
going that they're they're playing the
best football in the in the league
there's nobody playing i think better
more complete football than the green
bay packers and in that game with that
defense against the rams who want you to
throw the ball for aaron rodgers and
green bay to be able to run the ball the
way they did
and just physically dominate the line of
scrimmage over and over and of course
rogers doing his thing that was very
impressive but i'm just impressed with
the overall toughness of the team that
matt lefore has really instil instilled
there running the game run game the
defense how stout they become on the
other side of the ball there green bay
very impressive right now
and 28-7 for matt lafleur
including postseason games in two years
that is incredible and the way the team
has improved and look this is their
opportunity to settle the score with the
buccaneers team that blew them out and
they are drawing them up to lambeau
field that one seed's so critical but we
were rattling off uh in our brains some
of the uh uh
experienced levels out there playing in
the cold we've got tom brady you've got
antonio brown who played in pittsburgh
bronck who played in new england
defensively jpp played with giants
outdoors and dominic and sue played for
the lions indoors but still living there
lambeau feel in the cold remember the
game
when he stepped on the lower leg of
aaron rodgers at a time when rogers was
dealing with a calf injury right stepped
on it and pushed back on his on his
cleat they suspended him for a playoff
game it was one of the years yes the
detroit lions have been to the playoffs
it was a year they were going to the
playoffs he got suspended for the
playoff game and he beat it
with the argument
that his feet were numb because it was
so cold at lambeau field that day yeah
that was his argument yeah that was a
little bit yes
but that that's an element and little
and dominicans i mean look this is this
is a game it's the it's the pete axe
tell them people think that chris berman
coined the phrase bay of pigs it was
pete axtom who used to be on the nfl
primetime show with berman and tom
jackson axe tom was the one that called
it the bay of pigs the bay of pigs
meeting for the first time in the nfc
championship game and right now they're
the best two teams in the nfc yeah i
mean you know
we have gotten the best
final four that we could i think we got
the best four teams i think we did we
definitely we definitely did yeah i i
mean listen i i know
i picked the ravens to win the game but
you're i think in totality what we're
seeing here is yeah
teams that were consistently the four
best all year okay maybe not with tampa
in that conversation but we saw little
parts of the year where we went oh we
think tampa is one of the best teams all
year and they peaked at the right time
and we've been saying that for the last
month so either way the one thing we got
is four unbelievable quarterbacks too i
mean wow
the fact that we're gonna get to see the
two old timers and the two youngins in a
match up and then we're gonna get the
you know an old timer versus a young and
super bowl matchup is guaranteed right
now it's amazing it really is it's the
two greatest old quarterbacks
you know in the game and it's the two
greatest
young quarterbacks in the game right now
you know i know desean watson and lamar
jackson are in that convo but these are
for this year right now it's the two
youngest hottest best quarterbacks in
the game against the two oldest and
that's going to be amazing
well on that vein of quarterbacks my
next award you know we could do osu
greater than sign the big m but the big
m quarterbacks greater than sign the osu
quarterbacks because it was chad henny
the fellow tom brady michigan
quarterback who came in and got it done
yesterday when he needed to i mean you
you're conditioned as a backup
quarterback to be ready at all times you
spent a couple of years late in your
career as a backup you have to be ready
at all times but still how ready are you
really right i mean you're on the side i
mean how can you stay
explain that to me do you stay locked in
for three hours always like hyped up and
ready to get on the field i i can't
imagine that every backup quarterback or
even more than half of them are in that
frame of mind all the time it would be
mentally exhausting well it's not about
getting hyped up and doing that but
you're you are mentally exhausted as a
backup quarterback when the game's over
yeah that's the one thing you cannot
rest and sit over there and go oh i'm
just chewing gum you know shooting the
crap with the guys here we're having a
good old dandy time watching a football
game you know part of being a backup
quarterback is even when you're sitting
there on the sidelines okay here's the
play you hear the play as the coach is
calling in the quarterback so you hear
it and you've got to right away jim you
know start going through the gymnastics
of what is expected through that play
and then really as a backup quarterback
okay i used to you know you stand behind
the line of scrimmage a little bit right
so if the ball's at the 50-yard line
quarterback might be like 10 12 yards
behind that so he can kind of see the
view from the quarterback side and then
go through okay hey mike's 54 okay this
is what i would do we gotta oh all right
patrick mahomes should check here okay
patrick checks blah blah blah that
that's part of being a backup
quarterback you cannot mentally lose
your edge that way it's tough once you
get out there and have to deal with the
physical movement because you haven't
had to deal with that but he obviously
was mentally on top of it and that was
uh great to see
and the fact that he was able to make
that throw when he needed to on fourth
down shrugging off the interstate and
that killed the prior drive i mean chad
henny look wow that's the guy that they
have wanted to be the backup to patrick
mahomes he was supposed to play last
year but he was injured he got it done
and you know i was thinking earlier
about your song development and you have
a almost enough to fill an album now
between
the
patrick mahomes josh allen the original
aaron rodgers song you're workshopping
lamar jackson right i got an idea for
you okay for brady and i think it would
fit very well because you've had this
kind of lukewarm
relationship with brady the old barry
manilow song mandy i think you could
turn that into a very effective brady
song because it's kind of a very
mournful and regretful the way that that
the man had mistreated mandy you came
and you gave without taking and i sent
you away you could work that in because
i think you're starting to come around
i've sensed recently you're coming
around just as brady's getting close to
the exit ramp for his career to
appreciating what he truly can do i
always appreciate it i get sick a little
bit of the non-stop except when you call
him a cheater well okay i i think he did
there yeah i don't i don't hold punches
for anybody if phil sims took the heir
to the football i'd be going damn my dad
cheated too what the hell was he doing
all right sorry i just i don't know i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna lie because he
made a mistake i'm not gonna do that
sorry uh but i i have so much respect
for him i think he's amazing i can't get
over what he's doing i i really i've
told you this before and i'll say it
again i've had
so i mean i only have a handful of
autographs in my house tom brady's one
of them he was
my idol i mean he really was so i don't
i don't not like him one other thing too
with your kansas city thing that i just
think
we got a hit just because
as much as the fourth and one
was like a gutsy play call right i mean
unbelievable to call that play right
there with chad henny but man the chiefs
we've seen them what they closed out the
buccaneers that way they closed out the
dolphins that way they have a million
different ways to run those type of
plays
but
were you just as amazed as i was
on third and 14 that they even dropped
back to pass
i thought on third and 14 it's right
after the two minute warning i just went
run the ball
punt it
let them have it with a minute and 15
seconds left and let's see if they can
go down and score a touchdown in a
minute and 15. that's i was sitting
there when he dropped back to pass i was
like oh my gosh they're going to throw
it and i was going they're going to
throw in completion and they're going to
have the ball with a minute and 54
seconds left and it's going to be or
another interception or another
interception exactly i just i i mean
amazed and at least he had the
whereabouts to go nobody's open let me
just hold the ball
and whatever take a sack run but i was
amazed by that too and i just had to
bring that up one time sorry well that
was he almost got the first down i know
it was an amazing long run yeah it was
amazing it was amazing so yeah and and
uh the emotions of that game were
gut-wrenching gut-wrenching yeah
especially for brown's fans and i've got
a niece who who has suffered through all
the crap that the browns have been
dishing out especially 2015 to 2017 when
they went 4 and 44
and and she was she she was beside
herself but at the same time how can you
be upset if you're a browns fan about
where the team is because
because the future is extremely bright
they've got a great young coach he'll be
coach of the year and they get a full
year now
to get his systems in place and make
some decisions about roster get some
defensive players overall quality yeah
yeah this can be this can go very very
well for the browns and it could be that
next year at this time we're talking
about the browns having qualified for
the afc championship
my next one is the open competition
award because
it feels like that's what the rams are
about to do at quarterback
it started off as kind of a tepid
lukewarm assessment from sean mcvay
after the game he's spoken to the media
again since then let's hear from mcveigh
i assume this is from saturday after the
game when he's asked about jared goff
and his status as the team's quarterback
here's mcvay
everything's being evaluated i'm not
ready to make any sort of statements
with regards to anybody you know
starting position or not uh we're gonna
have a level of competition at
everything that we do
and so um that's where we're at and i
think uh you know being able to take a
step back catch our breath and evaluate
everything as we move forward and try to
be at our best that's that's my answer
to the question
all right i assumed incorrectly that was
from yesterday when he was back in l.a
the game day press conference he made a
comment at the tail end about jared goff
and he said yeah he's our quarterback
right now and those that right now just
kind of hangs well yeah as they end the
press conference like what right now
what do you mean right now like right
now like this moment like today and not
tomorrow so he he elaborated on that
well well but that
was no like gift of like oh like oh he's
are starting with even those comments
there i mean
hey look let's just be real here
if matt lefleur's asked that or a team
with a really big-time quarterback they
just go oh no no that that that spot's
not up for competition he's our
quarterback actually no what they what
they do is if it's bill belichick make a
face and roll your eyes right and don't
and don't even answer it like are you
freaking kidding me you're going to ask
me that question but there was a point
yesterday chris and i'm trying to find
it here in the transcript where mcveigh
was actually asked if there's a chance
that goff won't be on the roster next
year and he did not say of course he's
going to be on the roster it was that
same old we're evaluating everything i
mean that's that says it all and
you they need to evaluate the cap charge
that would be associated with cutting
golf before they come to that conclusion
they love to do full guarantees without
offsets meaning that if they cut him
just like what happened with todd gurley
you go somewhere else you you don't get
credit for at least all some of the
payment that you've made uh for the
money that you make elsewhere this is a
mess for them they never should have
paid him and i'm gonna go back to what i
said in june of 2019 when it was moving
toward them paying him and i was a
strong proponent of of goff being the
first one where a team says no we're not
going to do it and i don't know why they
did it and i'm sure they're asking
themselves now i don't know why we did
it chris well it it
you know it's gonna be
interesting to see i think those answers
kind of say it all that there is no like
they're not thrilled with them i think
that's the one thing you can know
by
you know reading between the tea leaves
over the last few weeks and sean mcvay's
comments you know even this week the
start of this week the fact that he
wouldn't name jared goff the starter
until middle of the week that said a lot
too just after he had just won a game in
seattle
i think there's too many games and too
many moments this year
where mcveigh the rams organization when
they go back and reevaluate the whole
season they're gonna look at it and go
wait the downfall of that game
or in the downfall of our team
throughout the year i mean the one of
the main proponents of that would be the
quarterback and the fact that they have
to manage them and the fact that even
the way the games played the other day
they have to manage it to a degree they
can't just drop back and go we're down
by nine we're down by 15. let's start
throwing the ball every play they still
have to run it and do blue legs and do
because they can't trust goff to make
those type of throws and bring back the
team that way so they're in a tough you
know predicament here i don't know where
it goes i will say
goff with the glove on saturday it was
very gutsy played tough
wasn't pretty but made a lot of you know
good solid throws to to keep their team
in the football game i want to give them
credit for that it's not easy but this
is a real conundrum that the rams have
and maybe maybe it's the blue pants but
he looks like 20 pounds lighter very
looks skinny right doesn't he look
skinny and spindly and yeah that's not
good either for long-term health in the
nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports